PLACE VEGAS, 27-16-3.
NURSE AND BOUCHARD ROUND OUT THE
STARTING FIVE FOR THE EDMONTON
OILERS.
BULEOD.
SHOT FROM THE
SHIFT IN A ROW W SO FAR.
>> Louie: BACK AND FORTH.
A LOT OF SKATING.
YAMAMOTO HOVERING CLOSE BY.
SMITH PROTECTING THEAND ZADOROV.
.
JUST STAYS WITHIN THE SURFACE.
NUGENT-HOPKINS DRAPED ALL OVER.
BOUCHARD.
THEN HE
TO MAKE SURE YOU ARE THE GUY
BACK THERE.
GOT AGGRESSIVE.
SNUCK A LITTLE FORWARD AND
MORNING.
WANTS HIM TO PLAY FAIRLY SOON.
HE'S GOING TO BE BACK IN ACTION.
THAT'S GOI
ENGAGED WITH BEN HUTTON.
DRAISAITL, THE LONG TOSS. EGREG.
HAGUE GAVE IT BACK TM,
WHAT, AT LEAST 300 GOALS.
AT LEAST.
THERED BY MIKE
THAT PLAYS A BIG PART.
HE WANTED TO MAKE SURE HE WAS
100% TO GET
DISHES.
ONE-TIMER!
BARRIE AND THAT WAS .
15 ON THE PENALTY TO THEODORE.
CECI WILL REGROUP.
WITH  NEHOWDEN SCORED THE
FIRST GOAL OF THE GAME.
DRIVES TO THE NET.E ONRUSHING
FOR DARNELL NURSE HE HAD THAT
LEFT SIDE.
JUD PINBALLED IN THE
CORNER WITH A SHOT BLOCK.
HERE'S DADONOV.
GETTING HARASSED BY BA
NICOLAS ROY SHRUGS OFF
NUGENT-HOPKINS.
PROTECTS CURLS INSIDE COGHLAN.
QUICK SHOHOAGAIN, NICOLAS ROY
THOSE ACTIVE VEGAS STICKS LOUIE.
>> Announcer: ALL DREAMS START
CHARGING FOR THE OI DUNCAN
KEITH.
I MEAN SOMETIMES THAT'S ALL IT
TAKES TO GIVE YOU A LITTLE BIT
OF ENERGY.
THAT MAY BE TURNING
HE'LL BEGIN WITIT
INTO THE SKATES.
NOT REALLY A PASTHROUGHOUT THIS.
.
DOWN THEPLE TIMES
TONIGHT.
BUT AGAIN UNDER DUES RIGHT
NOW.
FOEGELE WITH A LOB BACK TO
EXCERPT.
>> Louie: MIKE SMITH REALLY BRET
PAVELSKI FIVE MINUTE MAJOR.
CHANGED THE RULE BOOK TO BE ABLE
TO REVIEW THAT.